[Musique]
cet appel est lancé au président de la
république et à son ministre de la santé
membre de la fondation de liz schuh de
marseille j'ai pris connaissance des
derniers résultats des essais cliniques
effectuée par le professeur adultes et
son équipe et montre que l' association
médicamenteuse de ces 100 mg diderot
chloroquine et de 250 mg d'asie premiers
signes par jour pendant 10 jours des
menus considérablement la charge virale
des patients et donc leur contagiosité
cet appel est lancé monsieur le
président pour que vous permettrez à
tous les médecins français qu'ils soient
hospitaliers ou libéraux de prescrire
s'ils le souhaitent leur âme et
conscience ce traitement aux malades
atteints de colite 19 symptomatique
sachant que plus tôt le traitement sera
donné un style efficace et de ne pas
réserver jusqu'à maintenant compassion
sur les formes sévères empire aller par
une détresse respiratoire aiguë on le
sait il est souvent trop tard
j'invite tous les français à ne pas
s'auto méditer et à demander à leur
médecin hospitalier ou libérale de
presse et s'ils le souhaitent à leur âme
et conscience ce traitement
après éventuellement un
électrocardiogramme je suis cet appel
parce que nous n'avons pas le temps
d'attendre des essais cliniques qui
serait parfait certes mais qui
arriverait beaucoup trop tard pour
beaucoup trop de mayalde la question est
simple l'espérance peut-elle disparaître
la réponse est non parce que nous avons
un devoir de résistance oui nous
gagnerons ce combat
[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview
aujourd'hui nous sommes avec philippe
douste blazy ancien médecin ministre de
la santé sous la présidence de jacques
chirac
bonjour philippe douste blazy merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous sur rt france
vous avez repris du service aux urgences
de l'hôpital de garches dans les
hauts-de-seine à la mi mars et après la
région grand est on le voit les hôpitaux
franciliens sont aujourd'hui en
situation d'extrême tension
pourquoi en est on arrivé là dans un
pays comme la france
d'abord parce que c'est une catastrophe
sanitaire comme on n'en voit jamais
personne n'aurait pu penser que nous
serions aujourd'hui mon nom je vous
parle en saturation des lits de
réanimation en seine-saint-denis a quasi
saturation sur l'île de france
le pire c'est que les malades qui vont
en réanimation
ils vont pour 20 22 23 jours ce qui est
assez rare qu en général ça tourne
beaucoup plus stocker une embolisation
quelque part des lits d'hospitalisation
de réanimation qui pose un problème à la
fois un équipement aussi en personnel
alors pourquoi les les cliniques privées
n'ont elles pas été sollicités dès le
départ pour accueillir des patients il
ya une petite polémique sur ce sujet
également là aujourd'hui
les cliniques privées qui sont tous les
lits possibilit machine est de
transformer en
en salle de réanimation par exemple
toutes les salles de réveil
puisque nous avons déprogrammé
l'ensemble des urgences d'un ensemble
des des opérations non urgentes
ça a permis de transformer les salles de
réveil en salle de réanimation
toutes les fiches pour konami tes
billets par deux le nombre de lits de
soins intensifs et de réanimation on
peut pas aller plus loin c'est pas
possible
la seule chose qui peut compter
maintenant c'est la variable
d'ajustement c'est le confinement le
dépistage et le traitement à garches à
l'hôpital où vous êtes il ya une dizaine
de lits qui serait équipée de
respirateurs et qui ne pourraient pas
être ouverts mais cela ce sont bien sûr
les infirmières et les aides soignants
qui font défaut alors non aujourd'hui on
peut pas on peut pas dire ça mais je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui
pourrait très bien arriver parce que il
y à déjà peu de stock dans les masques
mais il y en aurait besoin
d'après ce qu'on me dit dans certains
cas de morphine en a besoin de poussins
on a besoin aussi de respirateurs et
donc là on est dans une machine de
guerre une médecine de catastrophe
donc on va en parler je pense avec vous
mais il y a des moyens je pense pour
diminuer ce flux de malades vous avez
deux sortes de cas de conscience
premièrement est-ce qu'on laisse un
malade chez lui il ya en eu là on voit
pas l'hôpital et deuxièmement une faute
est à l'hôpital jusqu'où on lui laisse
oxygénothérapie et à quel moment on le
passe en réanimation
surtout s'il a plus de 75 ans parce
qu'on sait que vous sachiez que rentrer
en réanimation
c'est quelque chose de très invasif
c'est extrêmement dur et donc après 75
ans la question se pose il vaut mieux
peut-être de l'oxygénothérapie dans un
premier temps vous désire on n'a rien vu
venir mais on savait que l'hôpital
public était déjà en souffrance
quand on voit la gestion de cette crise
et une gestion d'urgence le constat est
plutôt catastrophique pour un pays comme
la france
alors vous savez là se connaît dans une
guerre lorsqu'on est au front il ya des
questions pour peut se poser il ya des
questions comme s'opposera plus tard
donc le nombre de stocks de masques
je sais il a diminué normalement durant
les dernières années
il faudra faire des enquêtes sans la
regarder mais aujourd'hui on en est pas
là aujourd'hui il faut juste savoir de
leur en a des masses dans les hôpitaux
en particulier à celui où je travaille
et il faut savoir comment aurait des
pistes et l'ensemble de la population à
la fin du confinement est ce qu'on va
savoir si les gens sont porteurs encore
du virus et six plants porteurs du virus
tout faire évidemment pour qu' il soit
toujours en quarantaine et qu'on n'est
pas un phénomène de redon et puis savoir
si les gens sont immunisés oui mais pour
cela philippe douste-blazy va falloir il
va falloir tester les personnes à la fin
du confinement
le ministre de la santé table sur 20
mille dépistages par jour alors que
l'allemagne en a promis 200 milles au
quotidien au mois d'avril comment est ce
qu'on va pouvoir procéder alors je crois
quelque chose différent d'un dans les
tests dont vous parlez qui sont des
tests
pqr d'amplification génique ça c'est les
chiffres actuels et qu'il souhaite
qu'ils qu'on arrive à 10000 20000 deux
âges par jour actuellement
la question que je pose est est tout à
fait différente ida la famille
confinement à la fin de confinement et
va faire beaucoup plus que 20 minutes
par jour il faudra vraiment tester la
population française pour mettre à
l'écart ceux qui sont infectés
parce que des pays en effet ont une
stratégie différente comme la corée du
sud comme le japon et même vous l'avez
dit d'allemagne qui visait à dépister
très largement la population et ensuite
à mettre en quarantaine uniquement les
gens contaminés
c'est comme ça qu'ils ont des taux plus
bas et surtout et une mortalité plus bas
mais ça c'est fait c'est fait on en
parle plus on en parlera plus tard mais
pour l'instant ce n'est pas le sujet le
sujet c'est comment on se prépare
maintenant au dépistage massif des
français à la sortie du coffret les
conséquences sociales à la france a
procédé à des évacuations sanitaires à
grande échelle on a vu avec l'armée
réquisitionner notamment 49 lits ont été
mises à disposition dans des hôpitaux
allemands
où est la solidarité européenne philippe
douste-blazy et là aujourd'hui
la question c'est que l'épicentre du
virus il dit
en europe et maintenant aux états unis
donc dans ces cas là chaque pays a fait
ce qu'il a pu
là où l'union européenne n'a pas
fonctionné c'est tout à fait au début du
début du début sur la stratégie
comment faire comment on peut
s'entraider au niveau des premiers pays
touchés
là il n'y a pas eu on a vu que l'union
européenne ne fonctionnait pas pourquoi
parce que la santé fait partie de
manière historique des souverainetés que
l'on ne partage pas
c'est une erreur il faudra en tirer les
conséquences demain
non je crois que c'est une bonne chose
de voir que là mais hélas pour commencer
à sortir des malades très grave de l'île
de france pour aller dans des régions
qui sont pas encore faits touché mais
c'est vrai que tout ça va avoir une
limite
pascal moment donné tout tous les lits
de réanimation alors l'allemagne on vous
avez cité cet exemple moi également
l'allemagne dispose de 25000 places en
réanimation la france en compte cinq
fois moins là aussi quelle est
l'explication
là je pense que il y a un effet
plusieurs personnes l'avaient dit il y a
quelques années il y à une absence de
planification en france je crois que
nous sommes bons santé publique je pense
que l' agence santé publique france a
montré au début d'épidémie qu'elle était
parmi une des meilleures du monde c'est
comme ça qu'on a pu trouver le le
patient est zéro à contamines montjoie
c'est comme ça que on a pu retarder par
contre en terme d' urgence oui c'est
vrai que l'on manque de lits mais c'est
vrai aussi que nous avons tout fait pour
retarder le pic et j'espère accède cette
confinement sera remarquablement fait
parce que là la différence entre un
confinement moyennement c est un
confinement très bien fait c'est des
centaines de l'hydre air à la sorte
c'est un taux de mortalité qui baissent
également avec un ratio de 1,5
si le confinement n'est pas respectée et
qui diminue à moins d'un cil et
respecter effectivement le personnel
médical doit aujourd'hui faire également
ce qu'on appelle le tri des patients
certains patients considérés comme trop
fragile
sont écartés des soins intensifs au
profit des plus jeunes c'est ça la
réalité aujourd'hui
alors ça c'est un problème que les
réanimateurs connaissent quand même
régulièrement parce que il faut savoir
que lorsqu'on réaligne quelqu'un et
qu'on le met par exemple sous la
respiration artificielle
les gestes que l'on fait sondés est
extrêmement violents et donc au dessus
de 75 ans il faut se poser la question
peut-être qu'il vaut mieux garder un
patient de 76 soit 17 soit 18 81 ans
sous oxygénothérapie le plus possible et
essayer de lui faire passer le cap
plutôt que de le mettre dans un lit de
réanimation qui va d'abord prendre une
place ça c'est vrai mais qui aussi
peuvent être très délétère pour lui on
va parler un petit peu politique
monsieur douste-blazy vous avez été
ministre de la santé est ce que vous ne
portez pas une part de responsabilité
comme tous les ministres de la santé
d'ailleurs puisque vous avez poursuivi
le grand chantier de la réforme de la
gouvernance hospitalière en 2004 mises
en place ces fameux contrats d'objectif
avec le recul aujourd'hui vous aurez
vous auriez procédé de la même façon
moi je fais partie des gens extrêmement
humble et qui pensent que bien
évidemment j'aurais vu tout faire depuis
le premier jour de ma vie mieux que ce
que j'aurais dû faire je ne sais pas
vous si c'est votre cas en tout cas moi
c'est le mien et je pense qu'il faut que
je m'améliore tous les jours mais
puisque vous parlez de politique moi je
vais en parler je pense qu'il ya un
sujet c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
souhaité accepter votre interview
aujourd'hui c'est la chose suivante
c'est que healy a aujourd'hui une
possibilité de diminuer la charge virale
des malades mais on en parle
oui mais moi je m'en parler longuement
parce que c'est un sujet qui est
extrêmement important ce qui s'est passé
il ya 20 ans est certainement très
important que ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui avec des gens qui rentrent
en réanimation est encore plus important
donc il y a aujourd'hui un médicament
qui s'appelle hydroxy chloroquine qui a
été testé dans l'hôpital de marseille
associé à l'azithromycine 600 mg de
plaques et nine 250 mg à 6,3 me si ça a
été fait aussi dans en succursale de
l'hydroxyte eurokin en chine
maintenant la plupart des pays
commencent à le mettre en cause
de quoi s'agit t il s'agit de diminuer
drastiquement la charge virale du
patient au bout de huit jours donc
et je ne comprends pas comment le
ministre actuel que je soutient par
ailleurs et je le soutiens totalement
dans tout ce qui se fait et il n'y a
aucun problème je soutient parfaitement
mais sur ça je ne comprends pas pourquoi
il n'y a pas un décret qui permettrait à
tous les médecins français libéraux et
hospitaliers de prescrire la cobla les
drogueries chloroquine et la vitre
homicide puisqu'on sait aujourd'hui que
ça diminue la charge virale est donc la
contagiosité en luge
je ne comprends pas et je demande un
nouveau décret oui vous avez lancé un
appel en ce sens le 25 mars au président
de la république et au ministre de la
santé donc vous vous pensez que le
professeur raoul tu as raison de
préconiser l'hydroxyde chloroquine
justement pour prendre en charge les
patients et dès le début des premiers
symptômes
c'est exactement ça parce que s'il ne le
fait pas dès le début si vous réserver
ce traitement aux formes graves qui ont
déjà des pneumonies et un début d'un
suffisance respiratoires ce qui
aujourd'hui le cas du décret ministériel
on sait que des toxicos l'euro qui ne
marche pas donc nous sommes entraînante
nous sommes toujours en train d'entendre
aujourd'hui tous les conseils
scientifiques les grands responsables de
notre pays dire de toute façon on le
sera d'entre eux mêmes puisqu'ils y à un
texte qui est fait mais le test il est
fait justement sur des malades dans
pensée sur lesquels on sait que les 35
euros qui ne peut rien faire
donc évidemment les percements négatif
je pense à je pense que c'est
extrêmement grave parce que on commence
à regarder et le taux de mortalité qui
lie à à l'institut hôpital universitaire
de marseille et on va commencer à se
rendre compte la mortalité est plus
basse alors je le dis tant qu'il est
temps
il s'agit de vie je demande à ce qu' il
y ait une révision du décret
hydroxy chloroquine ça s'appelle la
nivaquine la nivaquine tout le monde à
la donner parce qu'on est allé en
afrique
maintenant 30 ans 40 ans ça fait 50 ans
qu'on sait que ce médicament est
totalement inoffensive ils ne font si
sauf chez les gens quand 80 à 85 ans
avec des troubles du rythme cardiaque
faisons alors g à tout le monde ça ne me
dérange pas mais ce médicament est
totalement voilà il ya une innocuité
total oui c'est ce qu'on comprend mois
puisque vous le dites vous-même il a été
prescrit pendant des années pour éviter
aux personnes d'être exposées au
paludisme sans précaution particulière
de la part des médecins pour quoi en
prendre aujourd'hui alors je ne
comprends pas on est on le dit de prison
d'être big emploie le mot gay quand on
est en guerre
et quand on sait qu'un médicament
diminuer les charges rival je suis un
peu étonné que brutalement on trouve un
médicament qui est totalement inoffensif
on dirait que c'est un poison c'est faux
quant à l'asie trop messine qui la
deuxième médicament celle antibiotiques
ne plus donner aux états unis il ya un
américain sur huit qui le prend et que
vous comprenez bien que si il était
dangereux on le saurait alors là elle
dit elle qui est la grande la food and
drug administration qu'il grand policier
des drogues et des médicaments aux états
unis vient d'accepter que des médecins
new york et puis cela prendre je suis
étonné que étant dans un pays où en
produits hydroxycut eurokin et s'étale
mais la botte en pharmaceutique français
qui le fait je ne vois pas pourquoi on
ne songe pas si dsk il n'y a pas un
risque du coup de peigne os x et les
américains le commandant masson france
est ce que les français en auront
d'abord j'espère mais d'après ce que
j'ai compris au niveau de ce laboratoire
qu'il n'y aura pas de pénurie pour la
france si on change le décret mais
encore une fois que l'on me dise pas que
ça ne marche pas parce que les
conditions dans lesquelles en l'étudient
aujourd'hui on sait au départ que ce
médicament ne marche pas le professeur
aourag a publié effectivement vendredi
encore de nouveaux chiffres il dit que
sur 95 80 malades qui ont été soignés
avec ce médicament 93% on avait plus de
deux symptômes 0 au bout de huit jours
moi c'est pas 2 c'est pas de symptômes
01 effet les symptômes baisse mais ça la
limite que quelques heures et la fièvre
et mal à la tête et des courbatures
c'est pas très grave il n'y avait plus
de dix russes
c'est à dire que je prenais l'exemple du
sida par exemple la trithérapie ça
diminue ce qu'on appelle la charge
virale et depuis on a modifié
radicalement les malades du sida qui ont
le sida
mais là c'est la même chose en diminue
la charge virale de ces milices de ces
malades qui donne du coup ne sont plus
contagieux et donc quand dira les
prochaines nuits et ville en moyenne ils
les gardent cinq jours ils repartent
et pendant ce temps il peut reprendre
d'autres et ces gens là ne s'aggrave pas
ils ne vont pas aux soins intensifs
alors il faudrait juste d'ouvrir les
yeux un petit peu et c'est pas parce que
il y avait pas des guerres de chapelles
enfin bref aujourd'hui il faut à tout
prix modifié notre décret alors les
détracteurs de cette méthode disque 93%
de personnes qui sont guéris
c'est aussi le lot chiffres que l'on
observe aujourd'hui en temps normal
donc c'est pas 93 % de gens qui sont
guéris en huit jours ça ce n'est pas
vrai a formé ses 93 % de gens qui n'ont
plus de charge virale et ça c'est
évidemment obligatoirement et un effet
du médicament qui est anti viral donc on
le sait in vitro on le savait les tubes
à essai là maintenant on le sait in vivo
je ne sais pas comment alors andy mais
monsieur raoul tu ne fais pas des deux à
côté d'eux
un groupe où personne ne serait traité
mes plans oui sur le plan éthique
aujourd'hui quand on voit que ces gens
là vont parfois même 2% ou 3% en
réanimation
je ne vois pas qui peut prendre
aujourd'hui le risque de faire un groupe
placebo en fait ça me paraît extrêmement
compliqué si c'est vous qui tombait ça
veut dire que dans tous les patients
traités par le professeur raoul personne
n'est allé en réanimation leur personne
et de la réanimation
il n'ya que une personne qui est décédée
qui avait 85 ans et une personne 74 ans
qui est aujourd'hui aux soins intensifs
mais 78 autres personnes n'ont plus eu
deux charges virales vont très bien et
ont eu des symptômes qui sont totalement
améliorée donc on va attendre quelques
jours mais je pense que la logique va
arriver et tout ça va passer à toucher
de lui-même est ce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui si ces personnes sont
immunisés après avoir contracté le camp
aux navires us alors ça c'est un second
test qui va arriver il faut que je
d'autres très rapidement de ce test là
c'est plus un test pour savoir si vous
êtes malade et si vous avez le virus et
savoir si bull avait eu et si vous avez
fait des anticorps si vous avez vous
êtes line is est il là c'est extrêmement
important de faire ça et je crois que le
jeune ministre de la santé veut faire
c'est à dire dépister tous les français
à la sortie du confinement générale pour
savoir qui est encore contaminé mais
aussi qui est immunisée si la condition
sinequanone pour que notre pays en
finisse avec cette épidémie qui n'a pas
de ces domaines de repos
quelle leçon en fera tirer de cette
crise philippe douste-blazy selon vous
allez il faut en tirer une leçon
d'arrêter de t'expliquer au ministre de
la santé que une ne sert qu'à demander
de l'argent que ce plat toujours pas
avoir suffisamment d'équipement et que
la santé ce ne sont que des coûts non la
santé
c'est la vie et que j'espère que et dans
l'après coronavirus le ministre de la
santé sera écouté parce qu'il demandera
des équipements hospitaliers que ce soit
privé ou
l'après coronavirus ça veut dire le jour
où on aura un vaccin lapointe
coronavirus non ces jeux après
l'épidémie ne fois que la peau
l'humanité sera immunisé que et donc que
ce virus ne nous fera pas peur comme
d'ailleurs le virus de la grippe ne nous
fait pas peur parce que même si on tombe
malade en tombe malade pour quelques
jours avec une petite température une
plus de fièvre pendant et donc laisser
ça là préférant d'un virus mais c'est
surtout je crois remettre notre système
mon jeu c'est à dire comprendre que la
santé qui peut y avoir des trams la vie
qu' il peut y avoir aussi la dame de la
nature qui est beaucoup plus forte merci
beaucoup philippe douste-blazy d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur rt france
c'est la fin de la grande interview
merci à vous de votre fidélité sur notre
antenne rester avec nous
[Musique]